SUSIE: There's a million fucking
women in the world.
Uh, yeah, the door was ajar...
Fuck are you doing in my house?
What is Jon Hamm doing
in my house?
He's starring in a movie,
and he's kind of shadowing me.
His character's based on me.
So, the character is
a disgusting pervert?
That's good. (CHUCKLES)
♪ ("CURB YOUR ENTHUSIASM"
THEME PLAYS) ♪
Hey, I'd know that tush
anywhere!
-Wanda.
-Oh, you know who I am? Okay.
Thought I had to turn around,
and show you my big ass.
You completely misinterpreted
that.
Hey, big ass Wanda.
No, I didn't say big ass,
I was just saying hello.
I was just trying--
Is that how you say hello?
Uh, well...
And what is that shit
all over you?
What you been doing,
scrounging around
looking for asses?
All in the bleachers and shit,
"Oh, where's the ass?"
Hey, what's up?
Is that Jennifer Anniston?
Hey, you guys made it,
what's up?
Come on in, man.
Come in. There's sushi
on its way, alright?
-MAN: Who are you talking to?
-Nobody.
Um, I'll see you at
the meeting tomorrow?
Yeah? Get some sleep. Dude,
seriously, you look a little...
(LAUGHS)
'Scuse me, hey.
Could I ask you a favor?
Would you please take
our photograph?
Just do it horizontally.
If you saw what I see,
you would definitely.
I got it up here.
-Just take it horizontally.
-Well honey, maybe--
Don't do this, okay?
You are constantly undermining
every decision I've made
on this trip.
Why don't you guys work
this out, okay? Seriously.
Oh, so no photo?
Yeah, I'm out.
I'm out.
-Oh, okay, thanks, thanks.
-Excuse me, is that you?
That's the actor in the show,
we just picked up our tickets
we're seeing you, the show,
tomorrow night.
Oh you're in the show tomorrow
night? Great, oh, I can't wait!
Because you
will...
fail.
How did you know that he could
ruin the show?
He's got this gift!
Everything he touches he dooms.
Watch this.
(GRUNTS)
Shit!
Ow!
I'm... so sorry.
Is that supposed to help,
"Sorry"?
Oh, thanks.
Ah, Jesus Christ!
What the hell?!
Did you shake that up
on purpose?
Parkinson's.
Ah-ha!
We gotta come up
with a plan.
I did Shakespeare,
I can handle this.
Is there a problem?
Yeah, there's a problem.
You vandalized my car.
Officer, a gust of wind came,
it blew a rake off of the, um...
-The roof.
-The roof!
-Off the roof of the house
onto the car.
-I was handling it.
Anyway, that's how your car
was damaged.
Alright, you're coming with me.
It landed on your vehicle.
Great, great performance.
I'ma break your fucking teeth,
or glass, or something.
If I don't fuck you up,
it don't look right.
What's going on, LD?
Larry want me to mug somebody.
You know what, this pasty ass
motherfucker got you into it,
have him get yo ass out of it.
I'm 90 percent to blame
for everything.
Ninety? I think 100 percent.
-A hundred percent to blame.
-Well...
I'm taking the lion's share,
I'm just saying--
No, take more than
the lion's share,
take the whole share.
-I'll give you a piece.
-That's terrific.
I'm so sorry again
for the delay.
I have diarrhea. So...
I'm gonna come right back
in a little bit
and check on you. Okay?
The idea of a spite store
is a brilliant idea,
I'm gonna open a spite deli.
What's left for me
in Hollywood,
what am I gonna win some award
or something, you know?
Anytime I see
a customer walk in here
that used to go to Herb's,
it's like my own tiny little
human Oscar walking in here.
Come and join me,
saddle up.
-Yeah?
-Yeah.
Okay, just grab on here?
-Yeah, grab on here.
-Let's see how we do it.
Yeah.
-Oh, this one feels good.
-Yeah.
-This is empowering.
Just this body position
makes me feel strong.
I'm really getting tired.
Did you consult women on this?
No.
They'll love this though.
Oh yeah.
What I find interesting,
in fact, fascinating,
is that you would go back
to a restaurant
where you and I had a meal
for the shear purpose
of harassing a waiter.
We split a check,
and he doesn't wanna
coordinate the tip.
Why should I?
Why do I need to coordinate
the tip?
You go out with a friend,
you tip in concert.
Why are we in concert?
There's no concert.
No, two different people,
two different tips.
The tip is a solo, Larry.
Thank you very much.
Listen, I had a great time.
-I got that.
-No, it's okay.
It was fantastic,
-it was a wonderful lunch.
-Seriously, I got that. Come on.
You can't just grab the check
if someone has the check, Larry.
That is absurdly rude.
I asked you to lunch.
This is my pleasure.
No, it's not, it's my pleasure,
Larry.
Give me the check, Rosie.
Give me the stole.
-Larry!
-OFFICER: Hey!
Get off of me!
Hey, what's the problem?
She's a professional crier,
and she conned her way
into getting that stole.
I'm crying, I'm crying, Larry!
That's it! That's it!
(ALL YELLING)
I can't take this anymore!
Pull the car over!
You're such a baby,
you're a grown man baby.
Can I say, we ordered this
kinda for the table,
and I feel like you've gone
way over
your appetizer allotment
at this point.
My allotment?
Well, there's three of us.
We each get a third.
Who makes up that fucking rule?
BOTH: It's an unwritten rule.
Oh my God, there's
two Larry David's.
Holy shit.
Pretty good.
Pretty, pretty good.
♪ (THEME CONTINUES) ♪